what we're going to do in this video is
talk about significance levels which are
denoted by the greek letter alpha and
we're going to talk about two things the
different conclusions you might make
based on the different significance
levels that you might set and also why
it's important to set your significance
levels ahead of time before you conduct
an experiment and calculate the p-values
for frankly ethical purposes so to help
us get this let's look at a scenario
right over here
which tells us raheem heard that
spinning rather than flipping a penny
raises the probability above 50 percent
that the penny lands showing heads
that's actually quite fascinating if
that's true
he tested this by spinning 10 different
pennies 10 times each so that would be a
total of 100 spins
his hypotheses were his null hypothesis
is that by spinning your proportion
doesn't change rather versus flipping
it's still 50 percent and his
alternative hypothesis is that by
spinning your proportion of heads is
greater than 50
where p is the true proportion of spins
that a penny would land showing heads
in his 100 spins the penny landed
showing heads in 59 spins raheem
calculated that the statistic so this is
the sample proportion here it's 59 out
of 100 were heads so that's 0.59 or 59
hundredths and he calculated had an
associated p value of approximately
0.036
so based on this scenario if ahead of
time raheem had set his significance
level at
0.05 what conclusions would he now make
and while you're pausing it think about
how that may or may not have been
different if he set his significance
levels ahead of time at
0.01 pause the video and try to figure
that out
so let's first of all remind ourselves
what a p-value even is you could view it
as the probability of getting a sample
proportion at least this large if you
assume that the null hypothesis is true
and if that is low enough if it is some
if it's below some threshold which is
our significance level then we will
reject the null hypothesis and so in
this scenario we do see that 0.036
our p-value is indeed less than alpha it
is indeed less than 0.05
and because of that we would reject
reject the null hypothesis and in
everyday language rejecting the null
hypothesis is rejecting the notion that
the true proportion of spins that a
penny would land showing heads is 50
and if you reject your null hypothesis
you could also say that suggests
that suggests our alternative hypothesis
that the true proportion of spins that a
penny would land showing heads is
greater than 50
now what about the situation where our
significance level was lower
well in this situation our p-value our
probability of getting that sample
statistic if we assumed our null
hypothesis were true
in this situation it's greater than or
equal to and it's greater than in this
particular situation then our threshold
then our significance level
and so here we would say that we fail
fail to
reject
our null hypothesis so we're failing to
this
this right over here and it will not
help us suggest our alternative
hypothesis
and so because of the difference between
what you would conclude given this
change in significance levels that's why
it's really important to set these
levels ahead of time because you you
could imagine it's human nature if
you're a researcher of some kind
you want to have an interesting result
you want to discover something you want
to be able to tell your friends hey my
alternative hypothesis it actually is
suggested we can reject the the
assumption the status quo i found
something that actually makes a
difference and so it's very tempting for
a researcher to calculate your p values
and then say oh well maybe no one will
notice if i then set my significance
values so that it's just high enough so
that i can reject my null hypothesis if
you did that that would be very
unethical in future videos we'll start
thinking about the question of okay if
i'm doing it ahead of time if i'm
setting my significance level ahead of
time how do i decide to set the
threshold when should it be 100 when
should it be 500s when should it be 100s
or when should it be something else